eravamo io thomas e ciccio avevamo in
mente di giocare una partita tranquilla
a rocket click
se non fosse che ci siamo trovati contro
dei francesi ed è scattato un poi
competitivo io vi metto la partita
intera ve lo giuro su dio guardatela
fino alla fine perché vi giuro io non
mai mai fatto una partita così mai nel
senso che era troppo troppo bella
dall'inizio alla fine troppo bella
guardate ve la prendete i sistemi quanto
minchia dura guardatevela tutta
miniatura non si può dire e belli
soprattutto il finale bellic guardatelo
buona visione
cliccate la spiaggia un lavabo test vero
questa è la partita che vale tutto
questo video dobbiamo battere un
lavandino che un pò bello il francese si
è capito i francesi pagano della beta ma
edizione ai ha fatto ci si forma un
lavabo you are francesino so why do you
don't have the be that you to the poor
no ok is right per youtube a world
francesi maledetto una tutela
[Musica]
l'om live from my brain del 2000 n
come ci sei preparare questa palla vero
già mandata via
è questa e tua la mente questo se tu
allora come nagy già un'ora di volo per
parast arval maraga un'aula tutti
francesi non possiamo perdere cioè già
ai mondiali non ci siamo
la vigoria sappiamo una una nicchia come
zidane dove matera insultate gli altri
qualcuno si faccia tira una testata che
ti buttano fuori luca cielo guardalo no
un lavabo attenzione bello messa più o
meno in c non lava ma occhio al timone
lavabo l'alfabeto volevi un altri cento
meno 34 anche nella propria città sono
in mezzo la sede dovrebbe semmai in
mezzo il rimbalzo dai 9 schifo toccata
la toccatela ha tirato chi te l'ha round
di nuovo per in mezzo
no era stato
le pigioni madonna che tira un brutto
come spiega mi ha spinto in regola ma tu
sei in scena hanno pagato i francesi che
si è venduto alla francia ciccio march
di you'll be your friend maledette
francaise abbiamo fatto una serie
abbiamo fatto tradito pure nel finale
perché dovresti avercela con me lo
voleva segnare ma si ok torna in pvb
commetterò vi farò mi farò per terra per
mesi visti in genere non posto fanno
parte onorevole provare a tenere alta la
dignità italia non ha provato pesa
questa roba finisce sul mio canale posso
mai mettere sul mio canale una roba dopo
dove parliamo con dei francesi no
c'erano esiste ma punto della moto io
stato in mezzo the picture of the
monnalisa isola
[Risate]
paralizzato nora guarda lo paralizza
siete concentrati a prima vista
dell'inizio vigilava se l'automobile
vuoi anche tu questa fantastica suoneria
battezzato non ho mandate testata il 48
2 48 e ricevi subirebbero testato da
ragazzi sembrano donato soli poi caduto
perché ha preso una testata la testata
gliel'ha data gina l'intera di utilità
poiché poi si è vendicato con un gesto
disgraziato e vedere rassegnato e
diciamo no ai mondiali adesso ridarci la
nostra gioconda i campioni del mondo è
nostra e nostra voglia la giocò a leo
materazzi e ha fatto gol è stato il
momento della mia vita
vado a destra me la sento che passa di
la palla
mamma mia che il missile attenzione
pericolosissimo non è vero lavorate che
sfiga che ora ti frego qualcuno tutti
dentro per l'amor del lavabo morto e
niente magari ricordo devo andare uno di
quelli
a rigori come nel 2006 dove fabio grosso
quando serve eccolo l'ha più grosso
fabio grosso
no inversa di 90 recinzione mica sto
sudando regala lo giuro sto veramente
sudan palla rivali dei team si fa
aggressivo it che sto sudando fortissimo
e chi è stato ma il francese proprio
minchia napoleone e gli stava bene altro
che esilio o gli occhi occhio ceo nokia
mai stimato ciccio ucciso subito
superato ciccio non devi perdere città
ma guarda le donne squadra ti sei
venduto una volta ciccio ciccio io io
poi lo re non sta male lo è stata male
può rarissimi bravissimi combo occhio
grandioso ma vaffan
tua sorella dai continuiamo raga
continuiamo gradimento verso questa me
la prenderò mai la prendo io ringrazio
il mezzo non so più a tortolì sky
mondiali in confronto sono tutorial nola
voci casa è come mai sofferto un credito
in 13 13 13 la guardo 13 anna beghe non
ha collaborato tutto attenzione hanno
più ora che non hanno più vinciamo noi
ha avuto via io
forse forse forse non è arrivato il tuo
posto francese marca male brutto gioco
[Musica]
di quanto vi manca a perdere picchia
pietro adesso rientro adesso mi scrive
pietro ha preferito perché non ha fatto
a sinistra intoccata più possibile come
possibile com'è possibile
c'e rischio lo spazzato via per fortuna
1 contro un onore
[Applauso]
vorrei farvi vedere come un ridotto la
mia sedia questa parità durata non so i
secoli bra tancredi vi basta e stato
bello
[Musica]